[ __ ] hello hello hello
I will be the best travel vlogger that
the world has ever seen
do it the markets allow this you enjoy
it man I do fine yep because I already
have my group things in writing and that
kind of part but I also like I like
travel vlogging it's different from like
hell yeah dude yeah you me both I think
I'm gonna get into the travel vlogging
the only thing that you have to do first
is just post regular content dude I'm
doing content you know people literally
email us on a regular basis asking us
how to do stuff in the influencing world
and you just get that shift free and you
choose to throw it away it's like I gave
you a bag of gold right you melt it down
turn it into a disc and then you throw
it out a window dude you're a piece of
[ __ ] you know what speechless I just
want to hear some funny [ __ ] too so we
were at a coffee shop right and Joe was
dropping these [ __ ] dimes of wisdom
on it
and Nick was just sitting there going
man this is some good advice and I was
grinding my teeth I said the same thing
for the past year also the way David's
away joe says it is just so much nicer
Oh cuz I'm not mean like [ __ ]
I was nice joe says it differently yeah
you were but you're still a dick I used
to be nice that [ __ ] went out the
[ __ ] window yeah you know you know I
think I respond better to meanness
anyway yeah I just got to call you a
piece of trash and you'll never amount
to anything and then you're like daddy
like my mother and I'll make something
of myself watch just wait it terrible
wait the way to you know which way dude
you know social media I'm actually doing
a live post right now
um promoting genius brain oh hell yeah
yeah that's dope
that's funny so why Nick how come how
come for the longest time David's been
pretty much trying to help you on your
business and you just been fighting that
what's going on no it's not that I'm
fighting it it's just I don't
trust David maybe he says I'm screwed no
it's um yeah well it's it's not just
that it's because I'm kind of doing
doing some Reba it's hard to type on the
computer when his hand is on his dick
all the time his [ __ ] keyboard sticky
dude it's like it sounds like you're
stepping on like I don't know glass like
a I call it the ghetto theater when you
go to those like one dollar theaters and
it's just all popcorn and candy on the
floor yeah that sounds like you any type
on my keyboard no I don't have a porn
addiction
it's just that I'm just really vamping
my own you know it's a lot of change the
since December so I'm revamping
everything yeah this all [ __ ] you so
you're you're actually you know very
talented and you're one of the best
trainers that I've ever had like you
know maybe you helped me increase a lot
I uh I lost 10 pounds and same with
David like there's actual progress with
you and I have a lot of friends who are
into fitness and all that stuff but the
funny thing is I think you don't treat
it like a business like I'm out here
every Friday you're pulling out money
out of your own pocket to have our group
things like where we train together I
didn't even know that see it all started
when Nick was a child and he had to pay
people to be his friends oh it goes
deeper than that god it's getting really
hot in here
we just which is funny to me because I
take it seems like you genuinely care
about fitness and you care about all
this stuff mm-hmm yeah well that's stuff
I take it as a work expense you know
it's something that um it's I'm kind of
testing some stuff in the water before I
kind of so you use that you use us as
guinea pigs are you get I use you guys
you know how people test the temperature
and water the app their footing in
therefore I'd say about a couple seconds
yeah yes look this foot in the pool for
six years yeah anyone that really [ __ ]
themselves the way that morally [ __ ]
yourself to the point of extinction and
then you you keep saying I'm testing
like how long you got a test for here's
the thing
it's you have to react to certain
stimulus that's put on yourself stimuli
oh yeah you're right I'm I'm just
nervous right now because it's so hot
here I'm just putting myself through the
fire and I will come out on top this is
it's just it's just the beginning of a
lot of change well if anyone's in the LA
area they should definitely follow and
check out Nick well at Nick the ear on
Instagram right they should get a
personal personal life advice because
their life will not change at all if you
want someone to complain to you I
complain to this dude like every morning
we work out together we cry yeah and I
think that's like the what a real
personal trainer is there for is to
[ __ ] build you up as a human being I
appreciate that man that means a lot
David what do you have to say your turn
had some nice things you have to say
about me I was trying to get you some
damn business because of how much you
helped me improve oh my god David you
have CTE and you forgot about too much
oh my god so I'm gonna go three but the
minute champion won't yeah you haven't
even done the countdown for the podcast
countdown well [ __ ] it
yeah well I thought we were already
shooting so I was like [ __ ] it we are
shitty we are shooting yeah man yeah but
I always give Nick [ __ ] because he just
doesn't care about his own life so I
have to care for no that's not what it
is that's me gets more excited is on the
sous-vide machine he bought he does
about actually making a career for
himself I I kind of envy Nick a little
bit because he he like he's he you know
he's doing what he loves right like he's
just training and fitness and things
like that and he's just it seems like
you're you you you get a
mal and you're just kind of cool like
you're coasting and then you're not like
I need to fight what's the next step
what's the next thing
Hawaiian it's you one of this it's a it
is but it just deep down I hide it
really well what's it
you're a Hawaiian dude man no no I hide
it very well you just you just sit there
and I simply make millions of dollars
really yeah cuz you're seeing a pouring
and Singaporeans are known to be greedy
as hell shouts all my peeps in Singapore
yeah I'm telling you man you want money
laughs I wonder where that comes from
that LA part is that that's just a part
of the Singaporean just that's just like
cuz there is such a mishmash of like
culture down there and like like they
speak they speak Mandarin like Cantonese
they speak Teochew they speak English
and they they all mix it in one like
Lane and English is their is their main
language yeah everybody speaks English
is are there Indians there there's a lot
of India and they all sound like
Singaporeans they don't sound like
necessarily Indian people they all sound
like Singaporeans and it's a very unique
accent it's like Malaysia because like
they're like brothers right but they're
yeah a lot of a lot of them are Malay
Chinese are yeah Malaya or Indo but I've
never been to Malaysia so I don't really
know how they speak over there sounds
the same to me they they use Malay in
their language - oh yeah that's crazy
cuz when you when you went was it that
was only like a week ago yeah I just
came back Wednesday last Wednesday look
what you do back in to your hometown
your it was it was great to go it was a
nice perspective change you're talking
about all the poor I am that we're not
toots out there and stuff yeah there's
like dude prostitutes or a thing out
there oh really they we're all coming to
just like take it away where well where
we stayed you're single now so you could
just hit that oh man that's why I'm like
the next what's the next thing the next
vagina what's the next vagina no I'm
just mad I'm so torn I don't even want
to touch nothing right now
touch myself well that's what my job is
as your personal touch me release you
yes and jag you off yeah prostitutes out
there we're gonna start again sizing up
with niggling so I heard you too late
yeah you're gonna jack me off or what's
up yeah anyway so um yeah the
prostitutes of Singapore there was a
there was a good amount and they were
coming in and out of our our the
apartment that we stayed at that's crazy
and there was like a bunch of them well
there was like you so you guys were
living in a brothel like what was going
on we live just in an apartment so you
Airbnb tour kinda yeah and then there
just so many prostitutes walking now me
and TIFF we left around a 4 a.m. to go
to our flight that'd be so funny they're
just regular girls like hey you don't
have to live this life I'm just going to
school laughs no they were like there
was like four girls just walking out of
at 4 a.m. and then they get picked up in
like a little very shady mercedes-benz
that was a very nice it's funny cuz
Singapore I I feel like it's so strict
and it's clean and it feels like a place
that's like like super conservative and
then it's like all these girls are just
[ __ ] all day yeah they're just
[ __ ] this podcast is brought to you
by attitude my friends hey have you ever
had trouble sleeping because you have
had the scratchiest sheets on earth
you're growing up my parents would buy
the most bargain cheapest cheapest
scratchy sheets I've ever slept on in my
life it felt like I was sleeping on a
bag of hay well let me tell you
something I got these attitude sheets
they feel awesome I don't know how to
describe how they feel exactly but if I
were to put it into words I'd say it's
like sleeping hmm sleeping with a
Angel's feather caressing your but
that's how soft and comfortable it feels
there's a couple of great things about
the issues that I like number one it's
cooling and you know about me by now you
guys know how hot I get I sweat like a
mofo
and not only does my bed have to be
comfortable but the sheets have to be as
comfortable as the bed so she's really
do breathe um keeps me nice and cool and
on top of that it's antimicrobial
because if you are a sweaty sweaty
person and I know that guys out there
you guys are musty that's because you're
dirty well guess what these sheets are
anti microbial as well so check it out
why not try attitude these amazing
sheets have a 30-day risk-free trial if
you're not fully satisfied you can
return your sheets for a full refund
they even cover shipping on returns edit
two sheets they're soft as silk
breathable as linen but at the price of
cotton you're going to love them when
you support our sponsors you support our
show and right now my listeners will get
a 20% off discount off their set and
free shipping just text brain to 6 4 - 0
0 0 the only way to get 20% off your set
of edited sheets and free shipping is
the text brain - 6 4 - 0 0 0 that's B R
a I n - 6 4 - 0 0 0 message and data
rates may apply it's dope cuz sing of
the crazy rich Asians did not do a good
job of depicting what Singaporean what
do you mean it's crazier it's better
well not the whole movie was shot in
like Malaysia so I'm so I've heard and
lo they only in the whole movie only one
person has a Singaporean accent really
and it's just like the mom with Ken Jong
right like that whole scene it's Ken
Jong Korean in there or he's supposed to
be I don't know what are you supposed to
be but he's American in the movie right
and then his wife is a Singapore woman
and but she's an actress in Singapore
she's like a poor but like I don't know
it's just comedian yeah I think she's a
comedy actor oh but the whole movie just
doesn't show like the true
like what Singapore really is because
the way everyone speaks in Singapore I
keep list I could talk to anybody and
they just have such a beautiful way of
speaking and they're so funny dude
they're funny as [ __ ] there was like
clowning on everybody it just so unique
to like most Asian like Chinese culture
and marine or Japanese that like
Singapore is just a very
it's it's very unique dude just the way
they speak the way they talk and the way
they tell stories you can listen to talk
for hours bro like you just get lost in
it can you well they speak English out
there so that's fine I was like how did
you understand what they're saying
sometimes you don't know what the [ __ ]
they're saying even if it's in English
we go some of the yeah sometimes I don't
know what they're speaking we go to the
hawker centre sometimes and they're
speaking that mishmash and I'm like I
don't know what the [ __ ] you do sir that
mission yeah I'm like huh
but it's just cuz like it's like the
older generation I guess but it's always
wandering to Singapore I've I've never
been but Vietnam in April for me that's
gonna go yeah Vietnamese I can't I can't
wait for that dude just because like I
grew around so many Vietnamese people I
would like to know where all that [ __ ]
comes from in a Vietnamese food man so I
love Vietnamese food you know people
love travelling to [ __ ] Europe and
stuff but I've never been enticed to go
to Europe me neither
I like Asia I like old European history
though yeah like Rome or whatever maybe
Greek Greek Greece Greece Spain reason
would be butyl Santorini yeah that kind
of places like the UK like Britain I'm
straight off that unless like they put
me in a like an armor night thing and I
get the sword battle somebody maybe come
on yeah someone's like hello my lord
that Cody [ __ ] yeah hello cough nah yeah
I want to be like around a bunch of
[ __ ] Christopher Columbus looking
people yeah that'd be cool that's what
she should do I don't want to go there
and it's like to get pillaged that's one
direction kind of people
you know what's so funny because when I
go to unless it's like you go to Paris
or France right you see a lot of this
this this architecture that's very
beautiful right Paris was sick right but
then I go to age and I look at these
temples that are even older than what
they have and it amazes me how somehow
they managed to first of all design and
create and then erect these buildings
out of wood just food makes no sense to
me I don't even live in seashells and
like [ __ ] bird's nest six hours six
hours of Ikea a coffee table yeah that's
what it takes me yeah and then you see
these people somehow
create this [ __ ] 30 high temple 32
high temple it shouldn't take you six
hours no it's just one piece of wood and
then four legs and it takes you four
hours yep yes IKEA does a shitty job of
presenting it you know what IKEA needs
to work on you guys need to work on
[ __ ] having a table where you just
screw something in a little bit and then
the whole thing just explodes
yeah how about how about you guys create
some that doesn't do that yeah sends a
[ __ ] and also the way they write the
yeah the way they write the instructions
is like oh we're supposed to know
exactly how this is done
we don't [ __ ] know yeah I don't how
to install install drawers and my
[ __ ] desk
I like how they got the picture to where
it's one person and then the guy is
sitting that he's sad and they put extra
room but it's four people this is how
many people you need and it's just one
little dresser but when you have four
people you all want to murder each other
at some point yes because no one's on
the same page oh you know where I want
to check out the Netherlands like the
whole Sweden and like all the I heard
Sweden unless it's actually really cheap
to go there oh really I'm not sure if
things aren't cheap to buy there but the
tickets pretty cheap because you know
these these from Sweden oh yeah it gets
good deals all the time and then he said
that it's very beautiful out there yeah
but there's not a lot of a lot to do oh
yeah cuz I just want to do the nature
[ __ ] yeah cool crystal clear like I like
a lot of nature yeah so a lot of people
go to Sweden for maybe like four or five
days and they'll hop over to another
part of you that's tight yeah when I
travel I want to see [ __ ] that I don't
get to see you yeah like I'm over cities
man like I feel like cities are the same
all over the world but that's where the
good food is yeah but then aside from
that what do you got you got the same
[ __ ] you got shopping you don't you know
like towers like I want to see culture I
want to see like [ __ ] monkeys in a
Cambodian for is that's trying to like
steal a purse I'm just afraid I'm gonna
just come back with some crazy disease
then you will alright knowing you you
probably will like it catch something
like an ape is gonna come up and just
bite my head run away out of all three
of us that'll happen to you Father I
know and then all my training will come
in I'm gonna Perry yes Perry
one of his heads uppercut him in the
chin and then hit him with the left
cross in the face
I think he's gonna bite your dick off
because that's what monkeys go for first
is your dick in your eyes perfect yeah
perfect that's what I want anyway so
David would probably die from like one
chance of a disease I probably died from
an STD and probably died from like an
infection from minders I probably like
trip on like a chord and like hit my
head Oh like one oh I like some stupid
[ __ ] like a vending machine will fall
care or something I you know when we
travel to Asia though like I think the
big reason why I like it is because well
maybe it doesn't apply to Singapore's
because I don't speak the language and I
have to figure my way around and I think
that challenging experience of
communicating I like that yeah because
it gets me out of my comfort zone and
also kind of puts in perspective for me
of my what my parents had to go through
when they came to the United States
thanks beginning [ __ ] English at all
and somehow they made a career business
oh [ __ ] that happened I don't get that
[ __ ] cuz I don't think if you drop me in
the middle of Asia I would survive yeah
they'd just be [ __ ] like I'm just I'm
just almost you shouldn't sleep here now
yeah I'm just gonna sleep outside try to
beg for money cuz I don't know how they
I don't know what their adaptation
process was to make that happen
I bet it was [ __ ] tough for sure
translated I'm not I know my aunt came
here too but then my dad had to kind of
figure out his own way but I feel if I
if I feel I think I'm assuming this but
I think that's why a lot of immigrants
kind of go towards religion because
these these unity that church community
comes and helps them out and they'll
help set them up and they kind of feel
that love and warmth from like let's say
like a Christian Church and that's their
introduction to figure out how to get
things going cuz I know my dad did that
when he had his church he would help
people who just immigrated here figure
their way out everybody needs a
community yeah and then they would kind
of fall in love with the community that
way just because everybody was so warm
and helpful right so I don't know if I
could do that though like I don't
understand how Asian parents or just
anybody who emigrates to a new country
just starts a new life
yeah cuz that scares the [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of me I'm gonna be able to do that
you know what though you'd be fine
really yeah you'd be fine what I'd start
mining outside of a Chinese I think we
have more access to info like [ __ ]
Google Translate and all that [ __ ] so
you'd be fun oh yeah we have Google yeah
we could just like type in whatever we
want and then like we're in Vietnam
don't read it be like [ __ ] I
know English
if you had to go to any Asian country
that they don't speak English they don't
speak your native language where would
it be and it has to be dangerous I think
that's okay that's a challenge because
if you go to a country that's like
already safe then you don't you don't
feel like weird there I think the
country that I would go to because it's
going through like an industrial
revolution right now Vietnam mmm really
yeah and I heard like Saigon is supposed
to be it's very modern right now and
they have a lot of great stuff their
fashion is coming up there a lot of a
lot of factories are opening there -
yeah so I think I would go to Vietnam
and try to make my way because China's
too boozy bujji now they're like [ __ ]
that I don't want to do it he's like
well I'll take it yeah well I can't I
can't go to China because Shane Gillis
says it's trash so yeah he's so right he
said there's ducks hanging around
everywhere I saw a duck hanging in the
we went to a hawker centre and I feel
like she's seen it before but then she
just like lost her appetite she barely
ate that makes me salivate yeah I'll go
to [ __ ] I'll go to aquariums and I'll
just start salivating
it was chicharrón she'd be like oh
that's five so weird what people are
like that with certain foods because if
you look at their it depends on what
culture you're from when you look at
their food yeah go the [ __ ] are you
eating it's not my best [ __ ] and it
really does show it's just like your
environment that you grew up in because
she eats like menudo and like posole
yeah and that [ __ ] is garbage soup
that's intestine yes it's delicious but
like if you think about what's inside of
it Kaka most people would have caught
dead eating it yeah yeah because when
you have menudo it's if they put tripe
in there they had all the every body
part it doesn't necessarily look the
most appetizing it's delicious but like
if you were to look at it firsthand
you would be like oh I probably don't
want it and I say garbage soup by the
way with the utmost respect because he
means it no I love menudo it's but it
still smells like [ __ ] from time to time
yeah depending on how who cooks it
because that's like the tricky part
about menudo when you go to a spot that
you don't know if they're not boiling it
off and cleaning it right it'll smell
might be like the or
but if you go to a place it doesn't
write a super-clean fantastic it's all
texture baby yeah that's all it is
pozole is way better to me though yep oh
so I like basalt more yeah I don't know
about menudo sometimes that just smells
like somebody dunk their [ __ ] [ __ ]
weird well we should get into the topic
of today so I have a patreon and I allow
people to ask this is was supposed to be
like a specific video that I could do on
like the regular videos that I do but I
thought this would be a better patreon
[ __ ] podcast topic and I don't know
because I don't know how I would answer
this is such a weird not a weird but a
very difficult question to answer so
this is was asked by Danielle and she is
asking for advice on how to peacefully
convince important figures in your life
to be less racist or homophobic or just
at least getting them to pretend to have
that much human decency would be cool oh
that's it
damn so she cares that much that she
needs to change the mind of her family
members that's tough that's that's the
part where I just don't know because
some people are so entrenched in their
own view specifically when it comes to
stuff like this like religion and I
think homophobia has a lot to do with
religion yeah you know one of my uncle's
was like oh we were just talking about
how homosexuality might be something
that you're born with like we're talking
about nature versus nurture and things
like that
and I was like oh they were thinking
that the the gene might come from the
mother's side of the family mm-hmm and
same with baldness and all this stuff
and it's just a pure biological talk
right yeah it's science but this guy's
so religious he was like nah he's like
our the female side of our family is
very religious so there's not gonna be
any gay people that's tight but I'm like
what the [ __ ] does that have to do with
that have to do a DNA like yeah good one
but yeah because I think cuz you and I
were too Christian to be gay yeah cuz
you and I both grew up been very
religious households yeah and so
I even remember I don't I'm not sure
this was a negative thing but even then
as adults like my parents as adults with
their friends within the church they
were trying to figure out what
homosexuality is they didn't even know
what it was they they couldn't figure
out how somebody could sort of date yes
how they could become gay
so I remember the commerce this is so
weird because it was such a random thing
because my parents used to have stuff at
the house called queer habits and Kuya
members are basically worship that you
do outside of the church and you kind of
do it at somebody else's house oh yeah
it's a great ordeal Bible study clubs
like that yeah so my mom would invite
people over she would create this big
old Korean feast they would you know
whatever eat have fun but they would
worship at the end of the day but I
remember sitting at the table and they
were talking about homosexuality and to
me even as a young person it was a funny
conversation because they were just
saying why are people gay in Korean I
and then somebody said the funniest
[ __ ] thing that I realized as an
adult he goes I think people are gay he
goes it might have something to do with
us coming from monkeys but they were so
inquisitive they were actually to me
were genuinely trying to figure out like
why are people too gay yeah because they
that's I guess because if you really
look at it from their kind of
perspective yeah just from a biological
standpoint homosexuality doesn't make
sense right because there's no
reproductive goal in it you just you
[ __ ] just if you just you're to find
this your same-sex attractive and they
couldn't really figure that part out and
they and then you know one person came
in with like that's the doing of the
devil that's the devil inside your heart
no you suck that like Christian JK news
but for old people and they were trying
to figure it out and I don't know if um
in this person's case like what what
their severity of or what they define is
what homophobia is right because some
people just can't understand what it is
and they just don't know how to wrap
their head around it so something that
either wasn't explained to them on top
of that or number two maybe they were
reprimanded for even having those
thoughts as a kid yeah they might be gay
and they're hiding it - yeah cuz you
know like some of the most homophobic
people are the most gayest people yeah
they want to be marching in a tribe
they want to have all kinds of
boyfriends or girlfriends you know but
they're like yeah um I I think like in
this person's situation she's probably
thinking like man I hate like being
around such ignorant people and it's
frustrating I can understand that
feeling because once you learn something
you you want to help people that you
love and care about to know it too so
they don't come off looking stupid but
you never change anyone through anger
and frustration like that's that'll
never work and by lecturing people
they'll just shut down even more
also yeah so you don't want to approach
the product you don't want to approach
it as if it's a problem you don't want
to approach it as if like something's
wrong with that something's wrong with
yeah you they need to learn because then
that's very top-down and what I mean by
top-down is like you don't want to come
off as better than anybody no one
listens to that [ __ ] if anyone that
tries to inform other people or lecture
them over the internet or just
face-to-face like no one cares and no
one wants to listen that's the worst way
to teach and try to help people learn
another way that people [ __ ] up is aside
from like what do you call it like like
being so combative about things is like
acting as if people should know already
mmm yeah you know yeah like people don't
know and they're acting racist or
ignorant or homophobic or whatever
because they don't know and you know
they don't know how hurtful it is or
whatever like no one's doing things
maliciously with that intent that's a
very very small percentage of people and
if people like realize that that's how
humans are we'll stop looking at each
other as like bad people or like hateful
people or you know I mean like that's
the best the first problem is that
you're looking at them as ignorant
hurtful mean hateful stupid whatever
like when you look at people like that
then you can't teach them and you can't
help them learn anything for me I think
a really great perspective flip is hmm
number one if an older generation in my
family they have very negative thoughts
about you know homosexuality or just
kind of like racial superiority type of
stuff and everybody beneath them
whoever they give birth to their kids
whatever my cousins or whatever don't
agree with them and they've already
moved on that means that generation is
already gonna die out yeah they've
already they're already done with their
influence and it didn't affect us so
we're fine so I wouldn't even I would
try to flip the perspective and say
that's how they are if you put your two
cents out there and you tried to
convince them in a very nice way and it
didn't work well it's gonna die with
them yeah it is gonna die exactly
because you you already don't think then
and that if that's your parents or your
uncle's or your aunts and they don't
really have an influence on anybody else
and these are just their personal
thoughts then I'm not saying that it's
right or wrong but it's going to die
with them yeah yeah so I wouldn't even
care to even try to change them I think
the best way that people do change is
when they meet the people that they are
racist against or whatever human
connections are usually yeah all this
[ __ ] happens because of tribalism like
you know people that live in Asian
bubbles or white bubbles or whatever and
like they're not meeting face to face
making friends with gay people or
whatever once you do it just changes
your perspective of what you thought you
had you know like especially if you
think that this group is an enemy like
oh this group always steals or this
group always you know wants to control
me or whatever yeah and when you dislike
something so much with a lot of passion
and fervor you will maybe not on purpose
but you will find things that you
dislike about that group way easier than
you would if you just like them so if
because you're looking for it exactly so
if you hate gay people you'll go on
Facebook and you'll find the articles or
you'll find the videos that will bolster
that opinion that get gay is bad yeah
why gay is bad right I think politics is
a perfect example oh yeah you're just
constantly looking for all [ __ ] lip
tart or yeah
you [ __ ] alright racist or like
you're just constantly looking for that
[ __ ] everybody's cherry-picking data oh
yeah whatever whatever circle you're
looking in whether it's like especially
in Fitness that's a big thing to where
people that are cherry-picking
scientific studies and they'll say oh
this is the reason why this happens or
whatever but a lot of the time too it's
when people are looking for issues as
far as to look for in a different race
they'll look
for specific issues or news stories that
are happening within that race or within
that sexual orientation and they'll make
a big deal out of it so a lot of the
times too it's like you can't really do
much from your point of view but I think
what helps is if you kind of come to the
issue with a little bit of empathy what
sounds crazy to be empathetic with the
people that are racist or sexist or
whatever but there's nothing else you
could really do but kind of change how
you react to those situations unless
it's a like for instance I have a
situation a personal story about how my
family someone in my family was a little
I guess you could say homophobic to a
certain instance but over time you know
just spending time with those people or
kind of understanding just like what you
said just being around them and getting
to know them as human beings you don't
really see them yet for that anymore for
being you know gay or straight or
whatever you just kind of carry on but
you have to kind of come from a point of
understanding with these people of how
they grew up yeah and it's not
necessarily their fault it's just their
expectations growing up and there's not
much you could do about it besides just
kind of change how you think about it
yeah I think the the thing that people
[ __ ] up when they try to teach others is
information never helps people like they
think facts and information and data and
like all this [ __ ] you keep spewing out
this stuff people don't learn that way
people learn mainly through experience
and their own self growth so like just
by being in proximity with like let's
say you never hung out with black people
but you're afraid of them because of the
news or whatever like you just think
that they're aggressive or whatever
because you see this on the movies um
and then you know you start hanging out
actually if you start making friends you
start realizing like oh [ __ ] there's
more similarities in the human
experience than differences for all for
everything I find so many more
similarities with people
not one is all humans are stupid as [ __ ]
yeah that is a huge similarity and a lot
of humans learn through feeling and
experiences and no one wants to admit
that they're wrong so that's why when
you spew information out at people and
you try to change their mind they never
do it never works but everyone argues
all day as if it's gonna change
somebody's mind yeah because you give
people certain just facts that'll shut
down their argument and even before they
even listen to what you're going to say
they have a rebuttal for it yeah so
there nobody's really trying to listen
especially if they're already entrenched
in their own view and they have an
emotional attachment to that hate yeah
whatever you say they're not gonna
[ __ ] listen to it yeah it always
starts with being vulnerable and respect
so like if any of us had something to
say all right and then you like I need
to be corrected or whatever there has to
be the rapport first and foremost for
you to be able to give information and
then that person receiving it and going
oh [ __ ] maybe I'm wrong because I trust
David I understand I we have rapport
we're friends I know he has my best
interest in mind so maybe he's
correcting me and I should really take a
look at this that's very different from
from someone who maybe not respect you
and even among friends this happens to
were like some friends are stubborn
because they don't think that you know
more you know better or whatever right
so it takes a very rational and a close
relationship to use information as a way
to teach someone Iran or or it's an
academic environment and you're you're
willing to learn and then you give
information out and then it's like okay
cool
so they gotta be ready to receive this
information and I think the only way you
can change someone is like it takes a
lot of [ __ ] work like all the time
and work that's why using info and just
spewing out facts is like the worst
thing you could do it's the shortest
thing then it's never gonna work so
you're just gonna fight and you could do
all the right steps to like show
somebody the right way to think mindset
wise but if they're not ready to kind of
accept that or they're not ready to
listen to you or whatever the case may
be they're never going to yea that's why
going back to what David said I think
the main thing is really being okay with
it like use that time to phone
on you and being able to control your
emotions when people say things that you
disagree with and people do things that
make you cringe that's what I learned
over time because every time I learned
some information or whatever I love to
share that with my friends and I want
them to elevate too or I want them to be
informed so they don't make the same
mistakes that I do and even though I
have great intentions I become too
preachy and I become too annoying an
argument of and if people most people
aren't that way you know like most
people don't like to sit there and argue
in debate and learn about facts and
things all day mm-hmm and it gets tiring
so that's like the worst thing you can
do and it does damage to the friendship
and relationship between you and your
family to know these subjects to are so
sensitive I find it really I find it
more the case than not that when
somebody tries to convince somebody not
to be this certain way usually attack
them they don't they don't come from a
place of like we said before empathy and
you're not really looking to change them
out of the kindness of your heart you're
looking to change them because you think
they're a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and when
you do that people already aren't going
to listen it's like when I when when my
mom and I in the talking [ __ ] it's it
clashes a lot because I'm probably goes
like you know why you're a [ __ ] idiot
days already off on the wrong foot yeah
there's there's there's no likely and it
kind of catches people off guard like
what the [ __ ] because if you know that
this is their ideal this is something
that they believe and now you're
attacking one of their beliefs yeah so
if you look at it like that then you
would probably be a little careful about
how you say things yeah you know this is
something that I think all of us can can
work on this is something that I'm
learning to work on a lot too because
when something rubs me the wrong way I
try okay you first of all yeah you're
right okay so I know this guy right like
I see he has a lot of potential I'm not
gonna mention who this man is right he's
talking about uborrow
there's a you know what you're such a
loser ass [ __ ] yes ted's Wow ten
reasons why
a loser a snitch and I could be very
rude and just be like that's not me
doing this okay but let's just start
this is there's certain specific cases
where this doesn't apply like for
example when you first meet somebody and
you they ask for your help
and you just give them these [ __ ]
Dimes right give them these [ __ ] bags
of gold and they melt it away and they
turned into a body thrown into the
middle the ocean right however those
people are a little different those
people deserve to be called stupid
idiots
and in fact surprisingly they're still
alive to this day because they haven't
just thrown themselves into the ocean
with that ball of gold
two more days because that's not talking
about me yeah we're not talking about
Nikki at all they said the guy his name
is Nick the foot that's what we're
talking about yeah another thing that
popped into mind was yeah like going
back to the whole controlling your own
perspective about things is like how do
you know if it's just your own
interpretation of them being racist or
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah maybe they're not
maybe it's how you view them maybe
you're racist maybe you're homophobic or
maybe yeah or maybe you're not um I
don't know unless it's blatant like
they're out there using the n-word and
stuff like that like I think that's kind
of what's happening a lot these days too
is people kind of read between the lines
a little too much not saying that you do
Danielle but like a lot of people do
that now where you know there was no
intention and there was nothing races
about a statement but it can be because
a lot of people project their own
insecurities onto that yeah like with
the with the with the SNL guy and you
know when I did my video on it I had to
sit and think about it for a while
because I had you mean the guy the Shane
Gillis guy yeah so I'll use that as an
example of something where I had a sit
on at first before I made a comment and
you know obviously the video that I did
is like 80% comedy 20 percent serious
right because it's just me just doing
what I do just trashing and roasting
somebody but in that case like I try to
look at it as the first time when that
video came out I was like people
probably have been a little too
sensitive because he's economic right
yeah so I'm wondering what that's about
so I watch the video probably like 10 or
12 times and I kind of sat there and I'm
like
I just rubbed me the wrong way and I
didn't know why and I was like why did
it rub me the wrong way and then I kind
of watched the video again and again and
I was like oh I know why it rub me the
wrong way it's because he wasn't making
a joke no there was no bit it was like
the bit was going somewhere and it he
went to the next one in the next one
like it was no it was too casual he just
said it like it was just [ __ ] was [ __ ]
talked like it was a matter of fact
that's what that's the great that's
exactly what it was just a [ __ ] talking
like oh this isn't funny no it's like
usually in comedy right like you make an
observation and then you flip it or you
revert like you do all these different
things are you hiding it right but what
he was doing was making a bunch of
Auvers age of observations and talking
about how disgusting it is exactly so
that to me is just [ __ ] talking and it's
not comedy yes and the fact that he
doesn't understand that [ __ ] is a
derogatory term mm-hmm that that to me
is like well dis was mad disconnected
cuz okay so I I did a Twitter statement
on this right and I'm like okay so if
this guy thinks saying [ __ ] is about
pushing the boundaries then why doesn't
he just go out and say the n-word
because that's really pushing the
boundaries for that guy yeah if that's
his comedy but he doesn't do that and
he's like oh sorry I pushed even hate
that reference to there was somebody
that left the comment and I had a
blocker because she was so [ __ ] dumb
she goes I knew that you were gonna
bring up that that n-word thing that she
and her observation was like you can't
use that because her statement was that
in her opinion that the n-word is more
offensive than you know saying [ __ ] and
I'm like first of all that's in
perspective to who you are is she black
she's black offensive to you because
you're black I'm Asian yeah like I'm
gonna I'm gonna think that n-word is
more offensive to me like no I I don't
have a connection to that one exactly so
that that perspective was so dumb and
then she went on to saying like she goes
till this day people don't know that the
n-word in the United States is an
offensive word and I'm like that's not
true a lot of people know I said a
majority of people understand that did
you ask anybody they they know it's bad
they still choose to say it they don't
even say the whole word yeah ma exactly
there's no there's no abbreviated word
for change nobody's gonna go check yeah
and so my rebuttal to that was my
point was in the video that I was making
was that people don't even understand
that it's an offensive word even when
they we tell them it's an offensive
[ __ ] word and it just goes over their
head because there's no history of
Asians speaking out about it and
controlling the word and saying don't
say that right so in our community we
know how hateful it is and there's a
racial history a part of it and all that
but that's why I think people like Shane
Gillis and I've been saying this all
that like for the longest time um white
boy comedians that want to go race humor
they know that Asians are a little bit
easier and safer to do the same
comedians that will never do black humor
or anything else they'll build they'll
test the boundary by doing Asian humor
oh for sure because traditionally Asians
just don't do this like I don't talk out
that let me they don't talk back they
don't do anything they just kind of like
move on and just or they don't even
watch the content so they don't know it
exists right but in like in the 90s
2000s in the comedy clubs like a lot of
these guys will attack that and but they
won't do Latino they won't do black they
won't do any of that stuff because of
that reason yeah and and that was the
the weird part of that conversation I
think for her I was kind of like what is
this the [ __ ] racial Olympics bit
yeah dude like I'm what is wrong with
you whether you either it's all okay to
say or none of it is yeah you know it's
like it comes down to that yeah that's
like me saying well well you know [ __ ]
is actually more derogatory than speak
so exactly why why well cuz you know
there was a war and you know agents were
actually killed and it's like so what
yeah it doesn't matter like I don't know
like why even write that [ __ ] comment
and the only reason why I responded back
because it wasn't a troll comment she
was trying to sound as if she was the
smartest person on earth that she wanted
to let me know about how wrong I am to
make that comparison to say that I
shouldn't be offended by the word
chinking comparison to how she's
offended to the n-word it's like first
of all that's not even the option should
be like well okay I'm I'm 80% offended
how about that yeah maybe 70% offend
yeah because then if if the n-word is
the hundred percent mark right of
offensiveness to racial words that maybe
[ __ ] can be like maybe we can negotiate
yeah it was such a weird deal because
her
poignant statement is to say that racism
is wrong but her comment alone is
already teetering on that racial thing
it's like you're not making it any
better right because now you're telling
people that you have a monopoly on what
our offensive racial terms are so yeah
it's not that's annoying - yeah it's
like hold on like you kid like I would
have step in your world and tell you how
you should feel about why did you get to
tell me how I should feel in mine
because you've had a personal experience
with the word that offended you I also
have that with this word as well and I'm
only speaking on my behalf you can feel
the way you feel I could feel the way I
feel yeah like what was it like I call
it the racial Olympics it's like no no
no it is yeah it's like well if black
people are the top like most oppressed
or like who's the top yeah you know like
they're trying to always compete yeah
and it's like why why does that even
matter we all got [ __ ] yeah exactly
and her opinion was she was saying that
I was doing the whole oppression
Olympics thing I'm like no I'm not the
example that I'm using is me tainted
this guy that he is comfortable saying
that word because he knows he knows he
would never do that with the n-word
specifically because he understands the
backlash that he would get cuz you're
calling out his ignorance exactly he's
gonna do it yeah I'm calling I'm talking
about him yeah but that's what people
get triggered no because you're calling
out his double standard news exactly and
and but also people like I said people
are stupid
yeah like that's the number one common
denominator all all races all culture
everyone's a stupid [ __ ] yeah and so
they don't understand what people are
intending to do and I think going back
to Daniels thing like you know you got
to check yourself and and and and even
control yourself it always starts from
the individual being calm controlled
like the not need to like control
yourself before you try to control
others so the need for you to want to
change someone's mind to inform them to
control them that says more about your
like kind of nature of wanting to
control others than anything and I think
if you did well that's just my
philosophy is once you just focus on
controlling yourself and your emotions
that's where the real power lies because
you can't change racism you can't
yeah how stupid someone is like they're
just gonna continue being stupid for the
rest of our their lives and I had to
tell that to a lot of my family members
too were like it's like we're you know
when they left the church they wanted to
rescue the other family members and I'm
like no let them be like that's where
their comfort is and that's what their
faith is and if they love that like keep
a relationship in all other areas and if
they try to preach to you let them like
do their thing and kind of like let that
blow off and go [ __ ] eat barbeque
yeah you know like there's other things
we can do they don't have to be pleasant
and everything yeah yeah that's very
smart because I I always how I would
explain religion to people sometimes
they go you know you you waste your life
kind of praying or - this this this
being up high and and I always ask that
well my response to that is this is if
somebody is doing something that makes
them happy yeah that doesn't affect
anybody in a negative way that they get
a sense of love and community for and
they die happy yeah and even if this
being doesn't exist what does it matter
you know you it's a win-win situation
they live believing in something that
made them happy that they believed that
they were living for a higher cause just
like in your case you're doing what
makes you happy and you live what you're
doing
the upside to them is that I guess their
gamble is that they'll go to heaven and
your thing is heaven doesn't exist it
shouldn't really matter to you yeah it
should unless they're you know like the
Westboro Baptist idea you know then then
then we have an issue right where it
becomes a little cult ish and [ __ ]
crazy and there's a lot of men like
manic beliefs that are [ __ ] up
everybody else that's something else
right but in that case with the family
members what are you saving them from
yeah what are you saving them from yeah
like are they so racist to the point
where like they're gonna get in trouble
for you know like you you think they're
gonna go out and start beating people of
the rings that they hate or whatever
like what are the consequences if it's
just a viewpoint you might want to just
focus on yourself
yeah and that's that's always my thing
is like don't spend so much time in
hours focusing on others like we all
have our own lives and our own hobbies
and our own path
and we all need to be a little more
selfish because that's how I make the
world a better place is by just focusing
on becoming a better person myself and
putting that energy out there and not
really do the not really try to inform
and control others you know yeah you'll
make yourself go crazy yeah yeah cuz
I've that's happened to me where like
when I was a lot younger where people
will say things to me or whatever
that's not very you know the coolest
thing to say and I see get so worked up
I said getting fights and stuff and and
used to have care to have this chip on
my shoulder until at one point I just
was like dude [ __ ] it I'm not gonna let
this bother me anymore
because there's not much you could do
about it at a certain point and
especially in the context of a family
member or loved one that does an axe a
certain way that you may not like
there's not much you could do about it
except for how you react to it yeah and
a lot of it is just come in a stomach
and say stop being racist or you just
say [ __ ] it I'm out of here yeah like
I'm not gonna put up with the [ __ ]
anymore and then you carry on with your
life oh I love abandoning people that's
where there's at some point there's not
much you could do because if you try to
have a conversation with them whether
even if you're coming from the sweetest
place ever and you're coming from a
place where you're not trying to call
them out and yet being understanding and
you're giving them in a scapegoat even
if you give that to them they'll look at
you in the face and say [ __ ] you you're
wrong you do [ __ ] to whatever you can't
you can't increase IQ you can't increase
people's viewpoint I mean you just can't
and there's nothing you do about it yeah
and and and and you have to make peace
with that like you have to make peace
with you know what this person may never
change I'm gonna love them for who they
are but you know if they do change
that'd be great and that's what comedy
is awesome yeah it's a bird you make fun
of them you know do you you can make fun
of them to their face around I mean it
doesn't help but it's it helps you yeah
my way of handling pee yeah like if
you're being a [ __ ] oh and oh you
know just slowly poke the bear slowly
poke the bear you know and it's just
like there's there's really not much you
can do you'll drive yourself [ __ ]
crazy
there's a problem I'm not gonna love it
well Danielle I hope that helped your
situation out I love this top it was
actually a really good topic yeah good
some major bombs there yeah some major
bombs and gems that's what I call it but
that that concludes this podcast I like
I like these like tapas it kind of
really gives us to get gives us gets us
to really focus on what subject yeah I
think people when they listen this
podcast sometimes I'm like where the
[ __ ] is this conversation going like for
example he will suck a dick for 750
thousand dollars come on baby
bring in those opera I did I got a
couple offers but I don't think they
have fun okay yep pumps Joe for five
pumps yeah dude yeah see see that's odd
one out
see that's why see that's why I said if
Joe was here it would have been a
different podcast see come on man
because you know what most people were
like you know what I like the way Nick
thanks and I appreciate that so shout
out to those people that are logical
it's also unrealistic no one's gonna pay
you
yeah no one's gonna pay everybody to I
I'm very realistic and that's why I'm a
business man cuz I'll be like hey five
pumps 750 they're like what [ __ ] off you
finish me off for someone who just to
let you guys know you could see how
flustered Nick is because he's very
disappointed you can't take that podcast
back it out there it is out there I
stand behind it because like what Joe
said and behind a fat dick if it's
really big
I'm gonna have to go up in price come on
back at the time
yeah but but back to my point what Joe
said earlier and I have to make this
point okay for someone to offer me that
kind of money I'm flattered yeah you
know I mean am i yeah you think for five
pumps that's worth 750 yeah hey dude at
the end of the day I'm just humble dude
if if someone just offered me that I'd
suck their dick for free because I like
to be yeah that's so nice discount 10%
off man I just want to hang after you
now so we're gonna okay you two suck
your dick that's a good deal dude see I
told you if Joe was on the conversation
would be completely different me and Joe
bro we we're on the same wavelength
hey man five dollars is five dollars
for that I want to go what's the what
would you do for five bucks looks like
that little nice I've some high five
somebody's if I'm down and out yeah
what's my life situation right now um
currently what it is now
oh if I need to smuggle myself out of
North Korea and I need the $5 so I could
pay the [ __ ] guard that's as good as
seven [ __ ] out of that dick and that's
why Joe is successful right and that is
how JK film started back anyways guys
that wraps up this podcast you could
catch us on all audio platforms that
stitcher if I - if you're on iTunes make
sure you give us that five style we're
trying to get up there in the rankings
Bay Babb yeah let's do it
this is the best podcast piece we talk
about anything and everything we don't
have any specific subjects we like to
keep everybody involved and we just
[ __ ] all day but she's every now and
then we get a weird [ __ ] guy named
Nick on come out everybody yeah shout
out to all the fans out there yeah
that's all the fans that would suck a
dick for 7:00 or $50,000 all right Jesse
uh next time